so let me tell you about a little game
called mobile legends it's basically a
mobile ripoff of league of legends that
was released back in 2016. and at the
time everyone just laughed at it it was
a hilarious clone a bit of a meme but
it's been no joke for riot they've been
through the legal system in two separate
countries and have failed to stop what
they see as a blatant copy of their game
it's a strange and often funny story but
what's happened since the legal cases
has been even stranger than you can
possibly imagine
all right it's another video of games
companies ripping off other games
companies it does happen quite a lot
this is perhaps one of the most intense
and famous examples of that but we talk
about it a lot here on this channel so
if you don't want to miss those videos
make sure you're subscribed to the score
esports and you'll get the clone news
every week okay so before we go over the
lawsuit i'm going to talk about how
exactly we got to this place because
it's pretty insane mobile legends bang
bang was released at the end of 2016 on
mobile by chinese publisher and
developer moon ton now as you can see
from its launch trailer on youtube it
looks exactly like league of legends two
teams of five fight across three lanes
and far minions to eventually destroy
their opponent's base now i'm sure that
some of you are probably already saying
yes okay it looks like league but mobas
are a popular format even league took
heavy inspiration from dota that's true
but for riot to get into a
five-year-long legal battle with moonton
there needed to be more than just vague
similarities here and there were they
copied the summoner's rift map even down
to where the jungle camps were they
copied the champions and their abilities
they even copied the logo in 2017 riot
filed a lawsuit in california against
ton to copyright infringement trademark
infringement and false designation of
origin in the 44 page lawsuit riot laid
out their case by saying that they
actually discovered mobile legends while
they were working to remove another of
moon games magic rush from the google
and apple stores riot alleged that magic
rush had copied dozens of league of
legends champions and included one
glaring example annie from league and
emily from magic rush two girls who
harness the power of fire and a pet
monster to destroy their enemies they
said that while they were working to
have magic rush removed from the google
and apple stores they discovered that
moon ton had been working on another
league clone mobile legends again they
included screenshots of both games for a
side-by-side comparison including the
summoning platform champion splash art
and the location of jungle camps on the
minimap it seems like they had a pretty
watertight case and riot is a big games
company who's backed by their even
bigger parent company tencent the
biggest game company on the planet not
only that they have methodically laid
out all the comparisons for the world to
see and it was hard to argue that
moonton was in the right here but they
didn't think so in an official statement
on the matter they said recently some
media have published negative and unreal
reports against mobile legends here is
the statement of moonton mobile legends
is a moba game that is developed by moon
ton independently and its copyright has
already been registered and protected in
multiple countries all over the world
moon has independent intellectual
property rights mobile legends and all
the users will not be affected by these
unreal reports and we will keep
providing the best gameplay experience
to players all over the world meanwhile
for some media and competitors who have
spread the unreal information and rumors
against us we reserve the right to
protect ourselves and pursue legal
actions it was fighting talk when the
lawsuit got to court though it wasn't
exactly the slam dunk for riot that
everyone was expecting at the end of
2017 those following the case were
shocked to find that the californian
court had dismissed it based on the
grounds of forum non-convenience what
this meant in non-legal speak is that
the californian court basically thought
they weren't the best people to rule on
this and suggested they take it to china
tencent being the chinese owners of riot
then filed a separate lawsuit against
moonton's ceo in china the courts there
initially only awarded riot 388 000 u.s
dollars but came back and amended that
to 2.9 million this was a blow to moon
tom but not a lethal one 10 cent was
bigger and short they'd won in court but
2.9 million dollars wasn't exactly the
end of the world for them moon ton are
the second biggest games company in
china behind tencent and for them this
was simply the price they had to pay to
keep doing what they were doing three
million dollars and we get to keep
knocking off your game
okay we'll pay that for over a year
moonton continued as normal with mobile
legends they continued to release
updates to the game which mimicked what
riot were doing with league
identity theft is not a joke jim as
youtuber nikolai pointed out in his
video about all of this the copying
became almost comical at times sometimes
this company operates exactly one step
behind riot riot makes an auto chess
game mobile legends makes one as well
wright decides to change the game's logo
after their 10-year anniversary and
mobile legends changes their logo as
well
specifically they change their logo from
this
to this
which looks a little bit familiar
they even have their own bootleg
champion spotlights but it really never
ends you just have to keep looking and
you'll find more odd similarities like
back when riot launched kda a k-pop
music oriented skin line mobile legends
did the same thing creating their own
music and everything in 2019 though
their position as the number one league
of legends mobile game came under threat
once again this time it wasn't from the
courts it was from wild rift riot's very
own league of legends for mobile game
when the game was finally released in
beta in october 2020 it was a big
success for riot within just three days
of its launch it became the most
downloaded app on the ios platform in
the countries where it was released for
beta testing it's interesting to note
here that these countries included
indonesia the philippines malaysia japan
south korea all asian countries where
mobile gaming is extremely popular this
is the market that moonton had tried to
corner with mobile legends and now riot
were on their back doorstep with the
real version of what they have been
trying to copy for years in 2021
wildlife rolled out across the world and
continued to increase in popularity and
around that time moon sent out a very
interesting survey to its mobile legends
players the survey began dear players
this is an online interview invitation
if you have played league of legends
wild rift for a long period we will be
very honored to invite you to
participate the survey then asked
participants if they've ever played wild
rift how long for and when the last time
they played it was i mean
this is kind of surreal imagine if valve
had asked cs go players the same thing
when valorent was released i'm not
saying that csgo and valorum are in the
same boat as all of this but you'd be
surprised if you got a survey with such
probing questions about a game's biggest
competition and it seems like perhaps
moonton didn't get the answers they were
hoping for in july 2021 according to dot
esports a player on onik esports said in
a since deleted live stream that moonton
is reportedly including an exclusivity
clause in its contract with
organizations competing in the mpl so
the mpl is the professional mobile
legends league with branches in the
philippines indonesia cambodia and
malaysia singapore yes this is a real
esports league for a clone game just so
we're all clear on the filipino site
they proudly declare that the mpl is the
largest and most prestigious mobile
games competition in southeast asia so
what this player was alleging was that
moonton were forcing teams in its league
to sign an exclusivity contract that
will prohibit them from competing in
other games such as wild rift the org
onik esports actually competes in a
bunch of different games including
valorum pub g mobile legends and wild
rift they actually won the wild rift
southeast asia icon series summer season
but two weeks after one of their players
mentioned the alleged exclusivity cause
they disbanded their championship
winning roster in wild rift in the
bigger picture moonton were kind of on
the back foot here sure they had got off
lightly in the legal battle but it
seemed that riot was ever so slowly
winning the war just a month before all
of this moonton had announced that they
were expanding the mpl into brazil one
of the fastest growing markets for
mobile games a 2018 report from nuzo
found that over 75 million brazilians
played mobile games that year and spent
1.5 billion on them so where are we now
well despite riot gaining a foothold in
the asian mobile gaming market they're
kind of late to their own party you have
to remember that mobile gaming has been
massive in asia for quite a while now
sure you might say that games like
mobile legends are cheap knock-offs but
they've had the advantage of being
around for years and do have a loyal
following wild rift is currently sitting
at around 6 million monthly players but
it pales in comparison to mobile legends
which sees 78 million players log in
every month this data comes from
activeplayer.io and according to their
graph despite the large playerbase you
can visibly see that mobile legends has
begun to slide a little bit since wild
rift really took off this year these two
games clearly share a market in fact
they couldn't share more of a market if
they tried wild rift is the game that
moonton set out to create all those
years ago when they made mobile legends
mobile legends were safe from this kind
of competition for quite a while because
despite copying league of legends they
operated on two separate platforms pc
and mobile now after years of legal
maneuvering and accusations these two
games share the same space can the two
games coexist peacefully possibly i mean
we've talked a lot on this channel about
similarities in games like league of
legends and dota cs go or valorant but
this feels different we talked on this
channel before about other games that
have been cloned there's project m the
valorum clone an area f2 the rainbow six
siege clone and creative destruction the
fortnite clone all of those games are
currently run by netties a chinese
company that is basically a pro at
copying games and avoiding legal
ramifications due to the rather lacks
laws in china around intellectual
property with mobile legends though
moonton are unlikely to release their
stranglehold on mobile gaming and riot
will keep pushing for a bigger piece of
the pie from the game which has been a
thorn in their side for so many years
a bit of a meme if you will how am i
saying if you will
no it's just i just i just added it in
unnecessarily
a bit of a meme if you will i have
myself
and when you said if you will again
after you made yourself
[ __ ] dying
i don't know why i said it